(upbeat music)
[Joe] Hey, Rob, this is Joe in Memphis.
I have a sports question for you.
Do you agree with me that
Tom Brady is a lizard person?
I think there's some compelling evidence.
I mostly go back to,
well, among other things,
he doesn't age like a normal human being.
He's won an inordinate
amount of Super Bowl rings,
but my bigger thing is
the clues given to us
by Bill Belichick.
Bill Belichick, I believe
is actually a hero
for our society.
He, I think in his own way
is trying to signal us
that Tom Brady is a lizard person.
He's never, Bill Belichick
never looks happy.
Even given all of the success he's had,
he always looks like a grouch.
I think if we were to watch
any of his press conferences
he would probably be
blinking in Morse code,
"Watch out for Tom Brady.
He's a lizard person."
So I want to know where you fall
and if so, if he is a lizard person,
should the Patriots and Tampa Bay
be stripped of all their
Super Bowl trophies?
Thanks again,
and I'll take my answer off the air.
Yeah, thanks, Joe.
I've given a lot of thought to this.
Look, as lizard people go,
I think it's, he ticks
all the boxes, Brady.
As you say, he does not age,
he's a freak of nature.
It's very clear that Bill Belichick
has been giving press conferences
like prisoner of war videos for years.
In fact, I always wanted
to do my interviews
like Bill Belichick,
and I would have loved
to have asked Belichick,
"Is Brady a lizard person?"
'Cause it would have been,
could be, I don't know.
And just thinking about
Kansas City next weekend.
I do like that Brady is in
the pretty boy hall of fame.
That's more important than being for me,
a lizard person,
is that he's a very pretty man.
And I have a very soft spot in my heart
for pretty men.
And I love to see him do well.
And if he is a lizard person,
it's made up for by the fact
that he is more importantly,
extraordinarily pretty.
Thanks, Joe.
That was a good question.